about a hundred years ago leading
entrepreneurs from the gilded age
like rockefeller and andrew carnegie were
fighting to become the world's first billionaire
this is a title that john d rockefeller the
founder of standard oil would end up claiming
in 1916. 100 years later we are starting to see
the race to trillionaire status slowly brewing up
now this isn't to say that today's
leading billionaires aren't any richer
as the billionaires from the guild of age
are multiples above today's top billionaires
after accounting for inflation but nonetheless
who will win the race to 1 trillion
well starting off just taking a glance at the
billionaires list it becomes clear that the
fastest growing billionaires by far are jeff bezos
and elon musk with the meech gaining 80 billion
and 60 billion respectively just this
year the other billionaires at the top
though still making tens of billions themselves
are gaining just a fraction of this this is
because they're either so diversified that they
match market performance or their companies have
matured to a point where the exponential growth is
mostly over as a result currently the most likely
candidates to reach 1 trillion first are jeff
bezos and elon musk starting with jeff bezos he
has had a tremendous run-up over the past 22 years
growing amazon from not even a billion dollar
company to a trillion dollar company of course
to match this exponential growth amazon must have
mind-boggling yearly growth numbers which they
do with the average relay growth of 82 percent
however that doesn't actually mean that they
go 82 per year because negative growth numbers
are worth significantly more than positive growth
numbers for instance let's say a company grew 900
one year and then pull back 80 the following year
if the company was worth 100 originally at the end
of the first year it would be worth one thousand
dollars after 900 growth but after the second
year an 80 pullback would bring it back to just
two hundred dollars despite eighty percent being
less than ten percent of nine hundred percent the
average return during this period would be four
hundred and ten percent but we know that this
is now reflective of the company's real growth
during this time period the company's overall
growth is actually 100 percent which is the same
as 41.42 per year which is still very impressive
but clearly nowhere near the 400 average return
so to calculate amazon's real return per year
we have to look at how much an investment would
have grown during the company's life if you put
in just 100 into amazon when it became public
you would have 65 538 today or about 65 000 growth
spreading that over 22 years we get an annualized
return of 34.28 or nearly five times the market
using this growth rate in conjunction with jeff's
current wealth of 195 billion we see that jeff
bezos could reach the trillion dollar mark in just
five and a half years or near the beginning of
2026 but the thing is most of amazon's growth is
already done in fact amazon stock stagnated
at eighteen hundred to two thousand dollars
per share for about a year and a half and if it
weren't for the pandemic driving more online sales
this would likely still be the case moreover
we may very well see a pullback in amazon stock
after the pandemic so it's not realistic to
expect this growth rate for another six years
to put this in perspective amazon would have to
be an eight to eight and a half trillion dollar
company for jeff to reach the trillion dollar mark
and that's very unlikely within the next six years
especially with them selling billions of dollars
worth of stock every year now he is investing this
money into blue origin which does have exponential
growth prospects however the main bottle cap in
this sector is the growth of the space marketplace
i'm sure in 20 to 30 years he could grow this into
a multiple trillion dollar company but within
the next 10 years blue origin is unlikely to
really grow its net worth significantly simply
because the space marketplace just won't be ready
in that time frame at least not in the trillion
dollar range blue origin may however become a few
hundred billion dollar company by then giving
jeff bezos another 100 to 200 billion dollars
but again amazon would have to account for
about 800 to 900 billion of jeff's wealth
so if we input a more realistic growth rate of 20
for jeff's net worth it would take him about nine
more years to reach the trillion dollar mark or
basically until 2030 but even that is quite high
and it's very possible that amazon is closer to
market performance over the next decade thus with
a 10 growth rate it would take 17 years or near
the end of the 2030s so though jeff bezos could
reach the trillion dollar mark this decade
if amazon continues with its exponential run
this is not very likely a more realistic time
frame would be 2030-2035 elon musk on the other
hand has a much better shot at reaching the
20 mark within this decade as his companies
are still in the exponential growth phase unlike
amazon similar to jeff bezos most of enos wealth
growth over the next decade will likely come from
tesla as opposed to spacex due to limiting factors
in the space market elon musk currently owns 19
of tesla however he gets another one percent of
the total outstanding shares of tesla for every 50
billion increase in market cap up until a market
valuation of 650 billion dollars of course he also
has to hit revenue and income based milestones to
cash out on this incentive but assuming he does he
would roughly grow his position to 25 of tesla and
that's assuming he gets no more stock after 650
billion evaluation and the respective milestones
as for how much profit tesla could be making
in the next 10 years if tesla is able to grow
into a high volume electric car maker that itself
would give elon hundreds of billions of dollars
currently volkswagen and toyota push 10 million
cars per year while tesla on the other hand is
targeting to push just hundred thousand cars this
year or just five percent but this is mostly due
to manufacturing limitations as opposed to demand
limitations right now tesla is aiming to produce
five hundred thousand cars per factory and are
building two factories one in berlin and one in
austin which will put their total factory count
at five just achieving their production numbers
per factory after these two factories are up
and running tesla would be able to produce two
and a half million cars per year if they continue
building two factories per year they would easily
have 20 to 25 factories by the end of the decade
producing about 10 to 12 million cars per year
as long as demand is able to scale up which is
quite likely given decreases in carb prices and
the fact that both volkswagen and toyota are
already able to support these numbers tesla
should be able to get to at least 10 million cars
sold per year by the end of the decade currently
tesla doesn't profit very much as most of their
profits go towards building new factories and
other capital investments however as they scale
up the cost of building factories will become
a smaller and smaller portion of their income
assuming they achieve a net profit margin of five
percent which is less than toyota's net profit
margin of seven percent and about the same as
volkswagen's net profit margin tesla would achieve
a yearly profit of 15 billion dollars at an
average car price of 30 000 which is significantly
less than their current average car price with
their current p e ratio of over 900 which is the
ratio between their profit and market valuation
they would actually be over a 10 trillion dollar
company but assuming the pe ratio settles down to
something much more reasonable like a hundred
which is less than where amazon currently sits
tesla would be worth one and a half trillion
dollars giving elon musk 375 billion dollars
giving him the same 100 to 200 billion
dollars from his rocket company spacex
elon musk would be worth 500 to 600
billion dollars by the end of the decade
and that's the very minimum as that completely
ignores tesla's autonomous driving technology
the robo taxi network through battery technology
and their solar business which is where tesla will
get most of its profit instead of selling those
10 million cars if tesla's full self-driving
technology is ready in the next 10 years they
can put those 10 million cars into the robo taxi
network from which each car is expected to profit
30 000 per year at that rate this fleet alone will
bring in 300 billion dollars in profit per year
even at just a p e ratio of 10 that would make
tesla a three trillion dollar company giving musk
750 billion dollars but it's likely that tesla
will have a p e ratio in the 30s as that's what
other mature tech companies like microsoft and
apple boast at a pu ratio of 30 tesla would be a 9
trillion dollar company giving musk 2.25 trillion
and that's still completely ignoring the
growth of a robo taxi fleet as well as any
profit from licensing the autopilot software or
battery technology to other car manufacturers
it's also ignoring the entirety of the solar
business not to mention musk space company
boring company and neuralink which could give him
multiple trillion each with all this being said
even if jeff is able to beat elon to the
first trillion elon will surely be the
richest trillionaire by far soon after heck he
may even reach 10 trillion by the time he dies
do you guys think anyone else could reach
a trillion faster comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys appreciate the depth
of his analysis and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered but until then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the next one